entertaining season is here which means
you got to get your brunch and breakfast
game up and I got you with this
delicious ham and swiss croissant bake
guys when I tell you this is the best
brunch ever let's get into it we're
going to cut up our croissants into
thirds and then we'll take some eggs
heavy cream and milk along with some
garlic salt fresh Rosemary and Thyme and
give that a quick whisk we're then going
to dunk our croissants in there and then
lay that down nice and pretty in a nice
baking dish and then you're going to
take some ham you can also use turkey
put it in these nice Swirls and I love
to use Swiss because it's going to just
give it that nice cheesy melt along with
some mozzarella I'm going to pop that in
the oven at 350 then I make this
delicious butter honey sauce with some
Rosemary and Thyme and I pop those out
and I drizzle that on top and guys when
I tell you chef's kiss try this out and
full recipe on my
blog